what's your favorite memory of being on  star trek i uh  god you know the thing is like there's  so many there are so many incredible  memories on stage  nine the stage where the where the  corridor is right it's where the  transporter room is more than once  teenage me walked in there walked into  the transporter room  pretended to be  beamed into the enterprise  walked down the corridor  to engineering  and turned on the engine  it's just neon lights  right on a timer so like they they  strobe you know but i knew where the  switch was  and i was like yes i will activate the  engines for the enterprise and i did  that so  so from one point of view teenager walks  down the wall walks through the set and  turns on the lights okay that's great  that's not what that was for me